[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
what if I told you there is a country
that has three presidents at the same
time with the problems that having only
one can bring imagine three at the same
time well such a country exists and its
name is Bosnia and Herzegovina and yes
with three presidents we could make an
entire visual politics sister Channel
dedicated exclusively to this country
along with having a tragic history like
few others is one of the biggest
political anomalies in the world apart
from having three presidents and 13
prime ministers is the only country in
Europe besides turkey with a Muslim
majority but that's not all if you have
noticed the name of the country is a
compound it is Bosnia and Herzegovina
why is this name you may ask well there
are two historical regions Herzegovina
is the extreme South of the country and
represents approximately one-fifth of
its territory the rest of the country
corresponds to the historical Bosnia but
if there is one thing that is really
anomalous in the country it is its
borders take a look at this man
literally we could say that bosnia's
borders are designed to be landlocked in
fact as we see below it seems that its
neighbors are conspiring to make Bosnia
landlocked what little they have is
about to be rendered useless
one of this is going to surprise you if
you have been keeping up with the latest
visualpolitik videos you already know
that Bosnia was the biggest victim of
the Balkan War the history of this
country is a real tragedy so the
question we are asking today is why has
Bosnia ended up having three presidents
why don't they have any Coastline why is
it that little Coastline they have may
be unusable today we're going to answer
all these questions but first let's look
at some history
[Music]
21 days in Dayton
[Music]
explain the map of Bosnia and
Herzegovina we have to go back quite a
long way in time specifically to the end
of the 17th century at that time
practically all the territory of the
Balkans was controlled by the Ottoman
Empire but wait all of it
no Dubrovnik that beautiful city in
today's Croatia was independent it was
known then as the Republic of Ragusa the
Republic of Venice which wanted to
expand Beyond its canals and control the
Adriatic Sea was also active in this
area to this end the venetians were
constantly conquering territories along
the dalmatian Coast which also belongs
to Croatia today in fact they had
already reached the borders of the
Republic of regusa so what do you think
the rulers of Dubrovnik did 300 years
ago
well nothing less than to create a land
buffer in the middle they basically
handed over that Coastal strip of 20
kilometers into which the city of NuMe
is located to the Ottoman Empire and so
they were protected against a possible
land Invasion by the venetians as it
happened the deal did not turn out badly
for Ragusa since it avoided the Venetian
threat and held on to its independence
until the time of Napoleon and this was
the strategy that allowed Bosnia and
Herzegovina to obtain its only access to
the Sea
[Music]
however to explain the other aspects
that make Bosnia such an unusual country
we don't have to go that far back we
need only go back to the 1990s 30 years
ago the former Yugoslavia was crumbling
and the republics that comprised it
began to reclaim their independence in
1992 it was Bosnia and herzegovina's
turn the worst ethnic conflict of the
entire Yugoslav war broke out at that
time
in Bosnia and Herzegovina three sides
fought against each other the bosniaks
of Muslim religion were struggling to
survive the others encouraged by Serbia
and Croatia wanted to divide Bosnia
there were the Catholic Bosnian croats
and the Orthodox Christian Bosnian serbs
the latter were winning the war Bosnian
serbs dominated more than half of the
country and became independent
proclaiming the Republica serpska
however the union of bosniaks and
Bosnian croats against the Bosnian serbs
changed the course of the war
the Bosnian serbs dominated more than
half the country and became independent
proclaiming the Republica serbska
however the union of bosniaks and the
Boston crew acts against the Bosnian
serbs changed the course of the war all
behaved like Savages in the war each
side tried to purge the areas under
their control of other ethnicities but
the Bosnian serbs got the upper hand
they held the city of Sarajevo under
siege for more than two years with
continuous shailing of Civilian
population and snipers doing their
sniping thing still sereniza was worse
the separinita massacre was the biggest
genocide of the entire Bosnian War there
Bosnian serbs killed more than 8 000
Bosnian Muslims
I guess this backdrop the West decided
to intervene and NATO launched a
three-week air campaign operation
deliberate Force the Bosnian serbs then
realized they had no choice but to
negotiate the Bosnian War had lasted
three and a half years the country was
devastated half of its population had
been ethnically cleansed or had fled
more than 100 000 people had died to
reach a peace agreement the leaders of
Bosnia Croatia and Serbia had to be
locked up for 21 days at a U.S Air Base
in Dayton Ohio and why not Europe you
can imagine in the Balkan War Europe was
of little importance so it was the
United States that sponsored the peace
and in Dayton the discussions were
detailed bordering on the Absurd you
imagine three heads of state who scored
to the United States to argue day after
day over little Villages over whether
such and such a village is in such and
such a territory in the end what do you
think happened with Bosnia and
Herzegovina well as something as curious
as the very name of the country is
deceptive if they ask you in a trivia
quiz why there are two entities into
which this country is administratively
divided no they are not Bosnia and
Herzegovina
[Music]
the two entities that make up Bosnia and
Herzegovina are the Republicans which
consists of the areas where serbs are in
the majority and the Federation of
Bosnia and Herzegovina in which the
bosniaks who make up half of the total
population of the entire country and the
Bosnian cruets live together the
Federation is divided into 10 cantons
five of the cantons have a Bosnian
majority three have a Croatian majority
and the other two well what can I see at
this point Clinton was already bored and
he told them come on leave it that way
with the mixed ethnicities because if
not we'll be here another 21 days in
Dayton and we'll have to send you the
hotel bill because this is costing a
fortune this sounds like a joke and not
just because of my accent but it's not
too far from reality the borders of
Bosnia are defined a village by Village
and that explains why it has such a
strange shape in this map you can see
the two entities the Republic of surska
and the Federation
this one shows the 10 cantons
as you can see there is no clear
division this is not north south or west
Easter single versus married the whole
of Bosnia is a real mess in which the
Constitution has enshrined ethnic
differences and this affects everything
infrastructure because of course
connections between points of different
ethnicities are complicated there are
139 kilometers or 86 miles between Banya
Luca the capital of Republica serbska
and sario evil which is the capital of
the country however the most direct
route is 190 kilometers or 118 miles
long and it takes three hours to make
the trip it also affected schools where
ethnic groups are segregated and of
course it affects politics where the
presidency of the country is held by
three presidents one representing each
ethnic group who take turning every 18
months to hold the office of Head of
State in short it is clear that the
bosnians were the ones who ended up
paying for all the hatred generated by
the disintegration of the former
Yugoslavia the question that remains is
does all this chaos work well we're
going to take a look at that right now
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ethnicities two entities and one
secession
[Applause]
have you ever thought that your country
has too many politicians well look at
the case of Bosnia four million people
lived in Bosnia before the war today
there are barely three million some
people think that with such a small
population this country would be better
off with a meal
however Bosnia has three presidents one
prime minister twelve other Regional
Prime Ministers and 14 parliaments with
about 700 parliamentarians and don't
think that we are talking about a kind
of decentralization in the style of
Switzerland not at all but in a
political bureaucratic model much more
similar to what is usual in the
Mediterranean all this and one of the
poorest countries in Europe where Public
Services leave a lot to be desired and
where politicians basically argue about
the same things that already LED them to
a war
against this backdrop young people
emigrate as soon as they have the
opportunity and the population continues
to age the system set up in Dayton has
only been useful for bosnia's
nationalist politicians who put the
benefit of their own above the common
good
[Music]
it is in this toxic environment that
Putin is trying to destabilize the
Balkans as we told you in a previous
video from months the Bosnian serbs have
been feeling supported by Russia and
their secessionist challenge in December
the Republic of serbska parliament voted
to begin its disengagement from the
Bosnian Armed Forces Judiciary and tax
system it was a statement of intent it
prompted the United States and the
United Kingdom to sanction milorad Dodi
the Serbian representative of the
presidency who suggested the Bosnian
serbs would ask their Russian friends
for help if nato intervened in Bosnia
and it's not the first time that dodik
has threatened the secession of
Republica surska but as you can
understand the whole thing blowing up is
much more credible after the invasion of
Ukraine for the time being they will
have to wait Bosnian serbleta dodic says
Ukraine war has delayed secession plan
for now it has been postponed for six
months but this plan signifies that the
Republica serbska will start drafting
new laws so that the Bosnian serbs will
have their own taxes their own judges
and their own Army something that is
very sensitive because of what happened
30 years ago in the war hold on a minute
because the Bosnian serbs are not the
only internal front threatening the
future of Bosnia and Herzegovina as a
United Country the Bosnian croats are
also reclaiming their identity
body and cruets have been complaining
for decades that any inhabitant of the
Federation of Bosnia and Herzegovina can
participate in the elections to elect
the crew act representative for the
country's presidency this means that
being a Bosnian crew at is not an
essential requirement to participate in
this vote a situation that is being used
by the Bosnian croat nationalists who
claim that the representative of their
ethnicity and the presidency is being
boosted to Power by the Bosnian Muslims
this protest intensifies at times like
the present when the Bosnian crew up
representative for the presidency
presents a moderate rather than a
nationalist profile that is why the
Bosnia crew at nationalist parties are
joining forces to demand changes in the
electoral law they're already ready to
go all the way and are threatening to
boycott the general elections they'll be
held next October Bosnian croats say may
push for own region unless election Law
changes so as you can see Bosnia and
Herzegovina are currently going through
a critical moment in which its
politicians are betting on accentuating
ethnic differences of course both Serbia
and Croatia are fueling these
differences in other words the stability
of Bosnia and Herzegovina is still in
question wait one minute because that's
not all remember this little strip of
Coastline well check this out
[Music]
a bridge leading away from Europe
[Music]
apply to join the European Union six
years ago as you can imagine Brussels
has not even granted Them official
candidate status it has simply indicated
14 priority reforms to be carried out
these concern its Judicial System the
guarantee of fundamental rights and
freedoms and the fight against
corruption but since then Sarajevo has
only complied with one of the 14 points
indicated by Brussels something which
distances Bosnia from the European Union
this was explained in mid-june by Oliver
vargheeley the European commissioner for
neighborhood and enlargement so at this
stage I don't think we can talk about
any negotiating framework Boston
Herzegovina has to fulfill 14 priorities
that have been laid out in our opinion
and which was confirmed by the European
Council at that time we're still waiting
the country to deliver on that meetings
with European institutions are ongoing
but internal tensions make it very
difficult for Bosnia and Herzegovina to
develop the reforms demanded by Brussels
so enthusiasm for the European Union has
turned to disappointment
Bosnia has just been overtaken by
Ukraine and Moldova which have suddenly
received the status of official
candidates for joining the European
Union a condition that Sarajevo has been
trying to achieve for years a blue that
comes with another piece of news that
has far greater significance than it
might indicate at first glance bypassing
Bosnia the massive Bridge set to
transform Balkan travel the foundation
works for the so-called plesiak Bridge
started in 2007 but the whole project
slowed down as soon as the Great
Recession began it was certainly not the
best time to build a bridge the project
ran out of money and was canceled in
2012. however Croatia never gave up on
finding the best strategy to bypass the
newham corridor take a look at this map
currently the road to the nurem corridor
runs nine kilometers or five and a half
miles through Bosnia and Herzegovina
until now this has not been a problem
Vehicles transit to this road and no
passport was required to cross the
corridor if they did not unload Goods or
passengers in Bosnia and Herzegovina
territory and they continued heading
towards Croatian territory but all this
is to change from 2024 when Croatia is
due to get something its tourism
industry has been longing for entry into
the Schengen air area
One requirement for the Schengen
membership is that Travelers and their
vehicles are checked both entering and
leaving Schengen territories in this
regard Croatia ruled out installing a
checkpoint in the Noom Corridor as it
would worsen the traffic jams that
already occur during the summer months
for this reason Croatia decided to
resume the project of building the
plesiak bridge in addition the pandemic
has already forced the croatians to bow
to the restrictions imposed by Bosnia on
Transit through the Noom Corridor one
more reason to push ahead with the
plesiac bridge which is nearing
completion with the help of two major
Partners Croatia's peljazak Bridge
financed by the EU built by China the
peleishats bridge will be inaugurated on
the 22nd of July 2022 and will become a
reality thanks to the fact that Brussels
has provided 85 of the 430 million euros
that's 438 million dollars price tag of
the piece of infrastructure
once this 2.4 kilometer bridge is
operational it will no longer be
necessary for tourists heading to
Dubrovnik to cross the newham corridor
this is a metaphor for how the European
Union is dragging its feet with regard
to Bosnia and herzegovina's possible
Ascension dashing its hopes well the
country watches other applicants being
welcomed with open arms a hard blow no
doubt for all those who believe that
joining the European Union would be the
best guarantee for Bosnia and
Herzegovina remaining a United Country
and now the questions are over to you
should the European Union bet on
incorporating Bosnia and Herzegovina as
it is doing in Ukraine do you think that
the Dayton Accords are a burden or are
they necessary for coexistence you can
leave me your answer in the comments
below and as always don't forget that we
have new videos every week so subscribe
to our Channel and hit the little bell
button down there so you don't miss any
of our updates if you like this video
like it so we know all the best and I'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]